former president barack obama can add a
new title emmy winner obama won the emmy
for outstanding narrator on sunday for
his work in the netflix documentary our
great national parks which is a
wonderful series if you haven't seen it
the five part series featuring national
parks around the world is produced by
the obama's production company higher
ground the late chadwick boseman also
got an emmy he was honored as
outstanding character voiceover for his
role as store i star lord t'challa in
the animated show what if and it was one
of the last projects for bozeman who
died of colon cancer of course in 2020.
his wife simone accepted the award on
his behalf
and the cbs concert special adele one
night only which was amazing won five
emmys including outstanding variety
special adele got an award as executive
producer making her a tony award away
from being an egot an ego an egot you
know some people want to be god's uh you
know it's good she's got the tea left
she'll get there i believe